the raiders marched into a new stadium
in los angeles kind of feeling like the
home team raider nation showed up to
cheer on the silver and black against
the chargers but it wasn't enough sports
director chris matthews is there live to
tell us what happened tonight chris
well guys i'll tell you what well first
of all let me say this boy sophie
stadium really is a beautiful facility
but it ought to be it's a multi-billion
dollar facility and raider nation fans
boy they showed up in force tonight as
las vegas came down from
from the north and they played in the
shadows of hollywood and it was supposed
to be a big star-studded night here in
los angeles but instead it turned into a
box office flop
sofi stadium was packed with raider
nation fans before they came out to see
their team but once again las vegas
comes out slow and the chargers had
vegas up against the ropes scoring 21
points in the first half now the second
half vegas showed some life scoring
touchdowns on consecutive drives the
second in the corner to darren waller
and las vegas was even driving to tie
the score but failed even missed a field
goal los angeles would answer with a
touchdown sending the raiders to the
canvas as the chargers went at 28-14
you know this hopefully wakes us up a
little bit
i think we need to start a lot faster if
i'm honest we started the season great
but we don't start games nearly good
enough yet and i think that's something
that we need to be better at
but
you never want to lose but it's hard to
win in this league
but we'll see him again
all right they certainly will see me
again later in the season boy three of
the four games the raiders have fallen
behind big in that opening half of
football maybe the best thing that
happened to them though is they're back
home next sunday to take on the chicago
bears and you'll hear more from the
raiders coming up in sports reporting
from inside sophie stadium i'm chris
matthews 8 sports now we are live local
now